problema número 49 nos piden resolver
esto raíz de 7 + raíz de 7 al cuadrado
bueno si tengo dos cosas iguales y lo
sumo pues voy a tener dos cosas iguales
2 x raíz de 7 es lo mismo que lo que
tengo aquí en el paréntesis y esto está
elevado al cuadrado y esto es igual a
tener 2 al cuadrado por raíz de 7 al
cuadrado 2 al cuadrado es 4
a raíz de 7 al cuadrado pues va a ser
igual a 7 y esto siete por cuatro es
igual a 28
que es nuestra opción c
muy bien siguiente problema
número 50 en cierta población hay tres
veces más personas de 21 años son menos
que personas mayores de 21 años la razón
de los de 21 años o menos con respecto
al total es vamos a notar lo que nos
dicen vamos a llamar x a las personas
que son de 21 años son menores
y van a ser las personas mayores de 21
años
lo que nos dicen es que están los
menores de 21 años es igual a 3 veces
los de más de 21 años lo que nos
preguntan es el porcentaje de x con
respecto a la población total de g
lo que nos preguntan es el porcentaje de
x con respecto a la población total y
cuál es la población total pues x más va
a ser igual a la población total
así que lo que nos piden es la razón de
x con respecto a x + x entre x + hagamos
algunas sustituciones estás aquí las voy
a reemplazar por 3 y me va a quedar 3
entre 3 más y esto lo hago si para
deshacerme de las 10 esto va a ser igual
a 3 y entre 3 yemas lleva a ser igual a
4 y las 10 se van y me queda que esto es
igual a tres cuartos que es la opción
no es necesario resolverlo de manera
algebraica si ustedes entienden que por
cada 3 personas de 21 años son menos hay
una mayor de 21 años pues será la
proporción de tres cuartos siguiente
problema número 51 de la siguiente
figura cuál es el valor de ese bueno se
me ocurre encontrar primero el valor de
x estos dos de aquí son ángulos
suplementarios ya que la suma de ambos
me va a dar 180 grados esto va a ser un
semicírculo así que 2x
3x debe ser igual a 180
2 x 3 x es igual a 5 x igual a 180 x va
a ser igual a 180 entre 5
y esto va a ser igual vamos a hacer la
operación 180 entre 5
veamos 3 por 5 15 18 menos 15 es igual a
3 bajamos el 0 6 por 5 30 30 menos 30 es
0 así que esa división de 36 x va a ser
igual a 36 por lo tanto este 2 por equis
va a ser 2 por 36 que es igual a 72 esto
va a ser igual a 72 este ángulo de acá
este ángulo
y este ángulo y este otro son iguales
porque son ángulos opuestos y les
recomiendo ver el módulo de ángulos de
khan academy para saber más al respecto
así que estos dos son iguales entonces
ye más 30 va a ser igual a 72 de esto
pero vamos a ver cuál es el valor de y
restamos 30 en ambos lados me va a
quedar
igual a 72 menos 30 esto va a ser igual
y esto va a ser igual a 42 y es igual a
42 y esta es nuestra opción
muy bien pasemos al siguiente
número 52 gaby y wendy empaca en varias
cajas con libros siga bien para que el
60 por ciento del total cuál es la razón
del número de cajas que empacó wendy con
respecto al número de cajas y empacadas
por gabi vamos a notar los datos voy a
ponerle g al número de cajas empacadas
por gavin y me dicen que gaby empacó
empacó el 60%
60 por ciento lo que me preguntan es
cuánto empacó wendy con respecto al o
empacado por gabi así que gaby empacó el
60 por ciento del total de las cajas y
wendy empacó lo restante verdad así que
winding empacó el punto 4 del total o el
40 por ciento sustituimos esto aquí y
nos va a quedar 0.4 de entre 0.6 de las
tres se van esto va a ser igual a dos
tercios y esta es nuestra opción
la siguiente pregunta
de lo siguiente cuál es la aproximación
más cercana de 50.2 por punto 49 entre
190 y 9.8 aquí hay que hacerlo con
velocidad entonces si me piden la
aproximación más cercana
voy a ver cada uno de estos elementos
aproximarlo a lo que me sea más fácil
operar 50.2 es muy cercano a 50 punto 49
es muy cercano a punto 5
99.8 es muy cercano a 200
ahora vamos a operar esto 50 por punto 5
es igual a 25
entre 200
esto si yo multiplico 25 por 8 me va a
dar 200 esto me va a dar que es igual a
un octavo y es mi opción ve muy bien eso
es bueno cuando encontramos opciones que
coinciden con nuestros resultados último
problema del vídeo
el promedio de 10 30 y 50 es 5 más que
el promedio de 2040 y x aquí lo que nos
piden es encontrar x
vamos a escribir estos datos el promedio
de esto es 10 más 30 50 50 entre 3 y me
dicen que esto es igual a 5 más el
promedio 20 más 40
x
entre 3 ok vamos a resolver este lado 10
30 50 es igual a 90 entre 3 90 entre 3
va a ser igual a 30
esto
es el promedio para que quede claro es
el promedio
de 2040 y x ok ahora vamos a tratar de
resolver esta parte 30 va a ser igual a
para poder sumar esto esto lo tengo que
dejar en términos de una fracción con
denominador 3 3 por 5 15 entre 3 más 20
más 40 y 60 más x entre 3
esta parte es igual a 15 más 60 es 75 x
entre 3 vamos a despejar x de aquí vamos
a multiplicar todo por 330 por 390 igual
a 75 más x 90 menos 75 va a ser igual a
por lo tanto x es igual a 15 que es
nuestra opción
y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo